I think Canadian candy tastes nicer
taste more polite because the people
have more polite yeah this sweeping
stereo day you do not get enough crisp
in your crotch is it made of moose
there's two I did not know that you
could have too much product but that's
what that is
it tastes a little bit more natural than
a Butterfinger I must say it's better it
like sticks to your teeth so one I would
not buy the minute
wunderbar I read it as Wonder Bra a
peanut butter caramel experience oh this
isn't a candy this is an experience look
at that yeah
that's a weird texture stringy funny I
like it okay you better swallow in this
it's like your friends that like won't
let fill these wunderbar I wonder why
they didn't make them easier to eat all
right I like it
coffee Chris they're very literal with
their names this is a graham cracker
with chocolate that's it oh this is a
nice one mm-hmm this is my perfect candy
who's a coffee flavored wait for Chris
Crocker bar I'm in heaven right now oh
it's here coffee in here no later at all
like maybe for your mouth and it's
crunchy at the same time yeah I would
eat these like crazy if they were
available to me oh it smells me bully my
goat that is strong too much is going
out of my mouth kind of like it though
this is definitely the best one so far I
like it oh my god I feel like I'm eating
a candle bitter amazing I've never heard
anything like this so flavorful
is this another form of currency in
Canada because I can see that everything
was good but I think I'm gonna stick to
my American chocolate Canadian candy
wins by spa I have to say American candy
only for nostalgia reason coffee curse
was like a revelation and I don't know
why it's not in America Canadian candy
has impressed me on the chocolate front
I got to see how they do gummy worms
though I assume that like America we got
candy figured out turns out there's a
whole bunch of candy out there that's
really good that we don't have
[Music]